alright guys bang bang I've got Ben
baller here dude is ready to crush it
thanks for doing this man I really
appreciate it I appreciate it bro it's
so funny just thinking sorry man you got
the New York cattle and I got LA head
also hilarious mr. burns that's why I
got a hat on because my hair is all
crazy can't get to a barber let's jump
into your background I think a lot of
people know you now as Ben baller the
jeweler I just got the songs and
everything kind of you know really
riding the top of culture but you had a
whole other life before before the
jewelry game maybe let's start just like
where you grew up and kind of your life
coming into high school and into college
well you know what's really crazy is be
like I'll give you like a four word
before we get into that it's just you
know being a big jeweler in the game and
it's without an ego you know um you know
people rate me the top three biggest
jewelers in the world I think I'm even
even higher than that in a certain way
but I mean I wasn't drew the year a few
times you know where some of these
people or 99% of the people on Instagram
never been nominated you know there's
millions of jewelers in the world and to
be recognized for not being Orthodox you
know I'm saying being fully unorthodox
t-shirt not wearing a button I'm not
wearing suits do you know tattoos
whatever else and but one of the reasons
why they were tattooed my face on my
neck my hands because I knew I was gonna
meet Saudis for certain people to get in
the room nowadays it's not necessarily
accepted because I think if you walked
into you know a meeting with some VCS
and Silicon Valley and Atherton you know
I mean your face aside like you know
about how much what do you make it's
kind of like I do like you know but
going back and forth um it wasn't until
about maybe two years ago even after I
won Julian I didn't consider myself a
jeweler and I've been doing this for 15
years it is my main profession it's my
longest profession but I always
considered myself a Renaissance man
because
all the things I had done in my life so
to go to the beginning I've always had a
love for hip-hop culture and you know
I'm 47 so when I grew up it was sort of
a taboo thing it was exotic it wasn't
really out there like that you know I
mean obviously rock and roll was
everything
it wasn't alternative back then it was
mod you know modern music me listen to
the Smiths and the Karen things like
that then there was like metal and ac/dc
and he got the country and like hip hop
was so so foreign um I just adapt it I
mean I didn't even like I was born into
it you know I jump I didn't even dive
deep in I was born anything trying to
search for it you know and you know now
today it's the biggest format of music
there is in the world pretty much where
I was the most influential it's crazy
so with that said you know I grew up
with a graffiti background breakdancing
DJ and you know uh I was just in the
streets I came from a father who was a
part-time minister was a he had he was
professor at UCLA for 30 years and my
father is very big on academics very
very severe super crazy traditional
Korean have to get [ __ ] straight A's
I'm the youngest of three kids my oldest
brother to give you an idea my brother
got a 1580 on his SAT score and when he
was 14 years old and my dad from in
hospital
cuz he missed the one question so you
know with that said um my sister she did
pretty well as well my brother went to a
school called Pope's caddy me and over
which is a very prestigious high school
we didn't have any money going up he had
a 90% scholarship and his boarding
school ought to see my sister went to
Exeter and then um you know my parents
got divorced and it was a rapid now
let's get straight A's the school
because I was get my ass beat and it
just wasn't for me
so our on 6th grade my parents got
divorced and I just was like I became a
latchkey kid the parents got divorced I
separated my mom
one custody but she's workaholic my
mom's totally different she was a dress
contractor
for most of her life and my mom just
always been a hard worker she came from
the era of when she could have taught a
harvard business class from just hard
work ethic and how to execute it right
well now it's you know you got to work
smarter you know a lot of people could
work hard right you got to you know
there's people who there's Mexicans out
here Hispanics out working insanely in
hard manual labor I'm not speaking about
that unless those people were able to
turn it into a landscaping business or
you know things like my mom just don't
how to do that huge reps putting the
sewing machine and like people like
forever 21 or like you know just people
he like like sheep I mom put the sewing
machine in a lot of people's hands and
they became very big and in the garment
industry and became some billionaire
billionaire companies
so anyways um I grew up in that
household and I was running the streets
DJing just wanted to [ __ ] listen to
music and whatever else and and I wasn't
a great student I think I graduated high
school like a 2.75 GPA I did get it like
a 13 something um SAT after three times
which is still pretty good I think the
basic stuff was like you know I think if
I took it one more I got better but um I
still couldn't get into any schools that
I want so academically and my dad was uh
you know was a head [ __ ] Asian
Studies you know he's he's the head of
asian studies at UCLA like didn't get to
UCLA and pay for [ __ ] scholarship
right so with that said um I I got more
serious about sports and I loved
basketball but I always felt like I was
a year behind and I don't know if this
it's something that I figured out in the
last decade which is crazy because I'm
been out of school for thirty years
right and like um I figured out that
when I left bar City basketball I was
like damn if I had one more year I'd
have done better but you don't have that
one year you know you gotta move on
but football I got an immediately even
football I could have even did better
and I kind of like slacked off but I got
a scholarship playing football to
Division one school you know so I get
into college good school um you uh you
know you enter a different
you're the [ __ ] all state all County all
CIF which is like one of the benefits
the conference in the California there's
not as many schools there's not the
programs that are now you look at high
school programs in Texas and their
football programs look nationally NFL
stadiums right and there it's serious
and you know I get to college and
there's 113 people at camp
the next day immediately 20 people drop
camp another thing is remember there's
no cell phones there's there's payphones
the payphone there's one and then
there's another one really far away it's
like a two-mile walk just to get to the
entrance of this Naval Academy in
Vallejo California and people just don't
want to do it and for some reason the
big doesn't really get hot like that but
it was really hot that day and people
were quitting everything else and my
first day at Camp I just noticed I
talked a lot of [ __ ] but I wasn't as
good as people I had guys and you know
that were 300 pounds and they're right
behind me
chasing me and I'm like Jesus Christ the
level of athleticism is a whole
different level I'm like man if this
gonna work and I have the coaches
telling me hey man gang you better step
your [ __ ] up you know what I'm thinking
like [ __ ] man you know we're gonna do
you know I mean I wanted to not go to
school but I'm here now so they make the
best of it and it was just crazy and
then someone stole my cleats the first
week of so they're talking [ __ ] to me
and everything else and it was a
struggle I get to school I had to play a
little bit here in there but I realized
because I wasn't a starter and I was a
star there was a lot of different like
you know like things that where they
could pull your scholarship you know if
you're not if you're not playing right
here in there whatever but meanwhile the
star players never saw him in class
never saw these guys doing anything the
homeworks getting done for them they're
at least getting a two point seven 3.0
average they're gonna get all their [ __ ]
taken care of they're the booster
program they're with the Alumni you know
I the guy who was pushing the gym lights
let him put lights and other things to
put the stands and the basketball courts
away I mean it would maybe take 15
minutes push all the bikes in a gym and
he was getting you know $50 an hour back
in like 91 and I'm like Jesus Christ
meanwhile I'm like still trying to
whatever so I figured that okay what am
I
do hear this is an academic school the
same working out so I end up
transferring over to a division to
school across the bridge of San
Francisco on top of that they had a film
school there which was Nicolas Cage his
dad who's a Francis Ford Coppola brother
Augusta Coppola he's the head of the
Dean of a cinematography there and so I
said all right we're looking I could
play basketball and football here I can
flourish kind of get this going and
whatever even still I missed home but it
was there that my love for the Bay Area
became like very heavy and you know even
though I was born and raised in LA I
have an apartment in San Francisco
although my business is in service to
the school and I was there way before
the the 2011-2012 Luber and all the app
smash and before even the dot-com
shouldn't everything right and I've
always had a fondness Co so that was
something the back of my head whatever
um finished college I start PA work
which is slave work and then I realized
said what the [ __ ] does this have what
is getting coffee building someone's
house grabbing someone's contact lenses
what the [ __ ] does have to do with the
film industry this is the stupidest [ __ ]
in the world like I don't get it and
it's just la you know everyone's coming
at LA to be an assistant or be business
in this and after like four or five
movies I like man this [ __ ] income so my
sister got me a job as a promoter at the
world-famous rock spread nightclub you
know night at the Roxbury Ryan is like
funny so I started working there as a
promoter and long story short I hated
promoting what a lot of celebs with the
end whatever and I was warned about the
wrong way like in like I would see like
Sylvester Stallone boom and people that
came in don't talk [ __ ] crazy you
don't talk to celebrities or whatever it
was it [ __ ] I was born a raisin Alaska
these guys I was just I thought because
I was part of the club I can kind of
talk these people bottom line is I kind
of started still figure in my way out
but my pastor was DJing and music so uh
one night the DJ didn't show up to the
Roxbury he was smoking crack and I had
an opportunity to DJ so I lived five
blocks away from the Roxbury this
shitty-ass apartment
the day I moved into this apartment
there was [ __ ] epidemic needles
epidermic needles inside the the [ __ ]
cabinets I'm like holy [ __ ] it was a
very heavy predominant like gay area and
whatever that makes difference just a
[ __ ] up place I was like you know what
dude it's cheap I'm very close to good
[ __ ] boom I go home grab my records come
back I'd do a pretty decent job they
gave me the night they're at a super
fraction of the rent and I'm like
[ __ ] I don't care that's trust one
good um a buddy of mine who was a very
good friend of mine his dad was
investing in a new restaurant and they
had a rest of them successful as only
soul food like high-end five-star soul
food restaurant that Denzel Washington
or Mixon Debbie Allen um this one black
socialite guy Brad Johnson they owned it
they're opening a new spot called Creek
alley and Denzel was one of the main
guys they're gonna make it like I don't
know how old you are on the back of the
day Moomba was like those a restaurant
but it had like music it had ambience he
also did two things so I was like eh man
I'm ready to you know so I waited
outside the [ __ ] place while they're
building this place and one day sure
enough there's this a gift was like a
retail store called 40 acres of mules
fighting Spike Lee's merch stop and
Denzel Washington's car was parked in
front of that so I just waited until he
came out I got literally waited it was
hours I just shot the [ __ ] with people
in the store so he gets there again my
[ __ ] tape I'm like a man I know you
opening the restaurant man I want to
give my thing and he's like something
like like why are you having this well I
know you like hip-hop and I want to
provide the music and if you don't like
this tape I'll work for free for you
know a year and I was working for so
cheap anyway I'll do whatever I could to
survive and sure enough you know a week
later assistant calls music hey man you
got a job here boo I go in there and
it's like a full state-of-the-art DJ
system it's far the nicest DJ setup I've
ever seen in the nightclub what the [ __ ]
and if not a nightclub was a bar to make
it restaurant from there I had I'd have
met people prior like from DJ I met
eazy-e dr. Dre rather a lot of rappers
that were working at this nightclub it
was all ages Club um the founders of the
club was my best friend Nick Adler who's
fathers Lou Adler rock-and-roll legend
Rocky Horror Picture Show Cheech and
Chong beyond like insane you know
California Dreaming moms the Papas to
produce that song like insane he's like
my you know kind of like my illegitimate
a godfather he you know helped me
tremendously with my career so his son
was my best friend loved hip-hop him and
David Faustino who was bud Bundy from a
man with children and another guy they
stride this club called ballistics and
it became huge it was that the world
famous whiskey whiskey a go go where to
beyond the doors every single rock bands
perform there James Brown and nicaya's
dad owned the place so we're doing this
thing there I was the DJ I met um I'm
trying to think of someone people would
know but will.i.am
who's the the leader back for the head
of a black eye piece a lot of people so
understand that wil like will I am was
the founder of beats by dre he actually
came up with concept and everything um
and he was a battle rapper just on the
stage broke no money nothing exhibiting
was a pretty famous rapper was up there
that's a pretty big underground hip-hop
people and it was it was a platform you
know and so you know I get this job and
I'm the first week I eat a there they do
the black Oscar party dinner I'm like
holy [ __ ] obviously Denzel you know like
I mean everybody Quincy Jones blah blah
whatever and then like right after that
I'm doing the black for hemming party
I'm like this is [ __ ] insane so I
meet Trey on the park
I do Jenny [ __ ] it's birthday so all
these people started to gravitate
towards me because I was a good DJ and I
was doing these things and one night I'm
deejaying and a couple fights have
broken out and people are like oh you
know they're like hey listen we don't
want this to be a stereotypical club or
a [ __ ] fights break out and there's
[ __ ] they're like oh they're worried
about drug dealers and all the racism
gets black people we gotta keep this
[ __ ] classy
yo man you can't play any music after
like 80 like four so you want to play
some fun you know some some Earth Wind
and Fire and some some al Green's like
that cool you can play with hip hop
bouncing [ __ ] man one night the owners
of the club they went to Vegas to go see
Oscar De La Hoya fight they're flying in
a private jet so we're watching the
fight
at the bar the general managers my boy
he was 15 20 years older than me and I
was like okay this guy would give a [ __ ]
he was messed with some chicks and I'm
new already he's by the book in his dick
sucked in the [ __ ] office he didn't
get [ __ ] what was going on so I wanted
to make sure these guys were going to
Vegas to be at the fight and at the
fastest they're gonna hang out watch the
fight maybe a couple drinks and then fly
back by a certain time back to LA so I
seen dr. Dre sitting down ready to watch
the fight I said I [ __ ] this complain
all hip-hop I'm playing everything that
I don't care if I get fired this is my
shot so I gradually go from the 60s 70s
80s and then obviously now the 90s Qurna
pop I take the fights off I take all the
sports off the TV screens and there's a
big boys and put all black exploitation
of film from Mac Superfly all the [ __ ]
and Dre's bugging everyone's in this
place NBA players Lakers of stuff and I
haven't got I lose my buddy I'm like a
man played for like 20 minutes I'm gonna
go to the bar and get a drink so I go
down everyone can see me I'm like
elevated way up in the sky and I go down
and I sit like ten streets next for Dre
and I know the train would you know and
sure enough dr. Dre is like Amen [ __ ]
you know about that music bro like you
Chinese will you like be playing all
this like real folk like you playing
some real [ __ ] like oh man my brother is
your age you know and um um I know a lot
about Dre then before the internet even
existed and I was like you know I just
been a big fan of hip-hop and uh you
know um this is what I'm doing and uh
you know what musics my life and so he's
drinking along iced tea I'll never
forget this is crazy right this is 25
years ago and he buys me a drink and he
goes no man do me favor man you got a
number and I was like back then I had a
pager
I had no cell phone no nothing I host
boss phone in that pager and the
Patriots like boom so get the patron
number and uh three days later like on
Monday he pages me to go to the studio
and bring some records next thing I know
I'm working with Death Row Records
I'm DJ scratches doing stuff I'm seeing
should and I'm seeing all this crazy
stuff I'm really star struck at this
point and I've been very little I've
been starstruck less than
handful of times in my life and then um
he tells me is a gay man you know I'm in
a situation here is kind of getting
tricky and this has been brewing up
between his beef with sugar is going on
and who's trying to leave after I try to
leave death row and start his own
company because there was a lot of
things I was like if you watch the NWA
story there's a lot of friction between
obviously eazy-e and NWA they all broke
up boom and then now is another
situation so I don't know what's going
on but as I came in I got a do you need
to talk to he's the daddy gave us our
first deal boom next thing I know I meet
this Jewish dude named Brian Turner who
owned Friday records and the craziest
thing these chicks that I was hanging
out with they're a lot older than me
they were five or six year old you know
when you're 21 and trying to figure
things out 22 and the girls 27 or 28
it's definitely you know it's a big
especially back then now it's like huh
but we're hanging out these chicks of
all four they were pretty hot one of
them tells me she just started dating
this guy and I was like oh man you know
like [ __ ] that dude you know and I'm
trying to like hook her all my boy
somehow some way I connect her with the
president party records whose enormous
mobile they get together they get
serious they get engaged they get
married they've had kids and everything
booms I was like part of that so this
guy took me in um I was in the mailroom
but I was I was in our manager so that's
like the the bottom of a NR but you
still got some clout you know and within
two years I became vice president of
party records you know we had jay-z
signed jay-z's first album deal we had
master P we obviously had a SKU and a
lot of things going on dre hits me and
says amen I finally got my situation
straight what you want to do I just
signed a two-year contract for $100,000
a year for the next year to be 125 I
have an expense account I can both eat
it [ __ ] Spago's or mr. Charles and
charge with the company I could even buy
like something nice every my whole life
so right off at this point everything's
free um I have flights I have a cell
phone and I just had everything had
great benefits like a full 1k
and Dre said he had a pretty decent
infrastructure but even had this
corporation of small companies I feel
what he won't do now this is the guy
that gave Dre his start pretty much and
I tell I told my boss I said I'm like a
man I got an offer you know I'm gonna
switching these things we've never had
any kind of static he's like you you
look kind of a punk kid you sound like
right now like I like you're young is
how you have a lot of talent you know
you doing well we have big things use
this I promise man stay here don't leave
but if you want to leave and go ahead I
didn't respond back to what he said and
he knew immediately so he's like y'all
did just just get the [ __ ] out of here
I felt bad but I was sold I want to work
with Dre you know he's a legendary dude
I don't work with Dre [ __ ] doesn't I'm
just sitting there Twitter my thumbs for
three years because I think he was
trying to figure out his life and
everything else but he signed Eminem
Eminem became huge um finally he drops
his second album it took six seven years
of dropping on it back then it's
ridiculous like now it's even ridiculous
but back then it was like unheard of to
wait that long to drop a solo album he
put out like other albums right but
anyways that being said I got Maus to
the mix that was no one I could really
work with we had eleven artists signed a
label none of that [ __ ] really mattered
because Dre was focused on mmm his solo
thing so I kind of signed a couple
papers them whatever meanwhile but all
this that's going on I became a pretty
big nightclub DJ um when I say big I was
like you know if you ever heard of guy
named Mark Ronson he's a very big DJ
very big
he's enormous now in the music business
and even more than that me and Mark were
probably very comparable to each other
in careers and he was deejaying all the
hype nightclubs in New York I was using
the best-loved in LA once a while he'd
fly to LA and guest spot I would go to
New York and guess what as well it's one
of those things I had a billboard in
Vegas before any of these big EDC like
all these nightclubs are having these
big deejays come all over the world from
Tiesto and Calvin Harris whatever so I
had a flourishing DJ career I had a lot
of clout of being head of A&R aftermath
but the music business just kept being
too political
amen we will make this record big this
year I'm like what are you talking about
like you're gonna spin this record here
I'm like man [ __ ] this chick like what
you talking about much play this was no
and it got political even in the clubs
where it was hard for me to say no one
play a record for two minutes you know
and then I started saying what panel it
was and things like that and bribes and
I was like young man I've let myself get
so infiltrated and so my mind got so
polluted and so corrupt with just so
pretty much I wasn't playing what I want
to play anymore and I was even playing
for the people anymore I was like doing
things and I just started to hate the
music business
DJing was like right the only last thing
left I leave aftermath I'm still DJing
this is the part that gets tricky I
started selling drugs and no cocaine I
know it sounds weird right I just I
wasn't dealing with the why cuz the
sentences were different you know you
get busted for we you know like if
you're selling a million pounds you
might get 10 years but I which is the
insane amount of time but you know you
sell you know a [ __ ] ounce of coke man
you go to jail for 30 years you know
this was different so anyways going on I
started selling weed and it was
profitable it was it was very well is
doing it very low-key and I was doing a
certain amount and I was running damn
near [ __ ] you know crazy weed [ __ ] how
did vacuum sealers shipping packages had
drivers going to interstate and
everything else I was doing that while
DJing and with that it was affording me
not to DJ for five minutes a week I
could TJ one or twice with only the
biggest premiere hot clubs were Paris
Hilton super bottles would be up at
[ __ ] Kobe you name it and I'd pull to
the nightclub in a Porsche and the
Porsche is four has it you know a trunk
in the front and I would bring like one
and a half crates I had an assistant
that came out and I just started getting
crazy whatever but throughout that time
I never invested anything all my money
was cash so with that um besides buying
like stupid [ __ ] like believe Vuitton or
Gucci and things like that
I was buying sneakers and enormous
amount of sneakers um when I got to like
100 200 pairs I was like holy [ __ ]
I'm not space for this so I'm moving to
a three-bedroom apartment in the valley
in San Fernando Valley in Sherman Oaks
California and you know people are like
when he heard three bedroom you know
launched buy a house and I couldn't
cuz I wasn't you know well not gonna
criminate myself on him but you
basically um I just said hey malmö sell
sneakers on the side right while I'm
doing this this and this now I mean
while you know drug money is cool I
wasn't like you know a cartel person so
like I was making good money but it
wasn't ridiculous to the point where it
was any retirement [ __ ] or anything and
I knew that this was a very short-lived
career until you get arrested whatever
so I was just finding sneakers and I was
stocking up on anything rare and it was
just something I had a hobby with spying
in 2001 2002 in 2002 Nike hit me up
because I've been on the the early very
early sneaker message forums there was
only two one of them was very big was
called Nike talked and was no
affiliation of Nike but it was a Nike
fan site and this this thing produced a
lot of enormous people Kanye West was on
their little rappers a lot lot a lot of
big Street where people and we would do
buying trades and sells and there was
like it was like the first social media
like we would post what you wear today
Oh what shoes you know boom and sneaker
buyers are going up and up and up and we
started realizing this is like baseball
cards but on a whole different level so
around 2003 late 2003 I have about 1800
personal pairs of sneakers 1,800 people
who have 500 pairs today are considered
like insane sneaker collectors right I
remember 500 while mom said you know you
had a couple hours like a you know
hundred pairs of shoes a lot you know
you know maybe something's wrong with
you you know maybe I should go see so
I'm gonna see you know um you know
consult if maybe you mentally you're
okay maybe something's wrong with your
brain then it got to 500 and she's like
a man you know something maybe is really
wrong with you and at a point she'd
understand it was a business and I
didn't understand it was business I was
bartering I was some things but I was
buying [ __ ] just to support my habit if
I didn't like the parish's I was buying
three pairs so people couldn't get one I
just had built these connections
throughout Tokyo London New York Philly
um some parts of Atlanta
Baltimore and I was doing all this [ __ ]
and you know working with Nike doing
marketing campaigns with them
I haven't fall
one night the same way I do it the music
business it became very political very
and I don't care listen at this point
I'll speak freely
I heard the gap is run or it was run
very like not like Scientology but it
was really run like very strict like a
weird thing that'll do distances I
started noticing that like I was wearing
a polo one day and I get an email okay
uh yeah we make polos at Nike so you
can't wear a polo into the stores
consider competition we do parties at
this house was an energy house and she's
like yeah we saw that you put a flyer on
like you talked you said parties we
don't do parties at Nike we do events
all right here we go try to influence
the narrative and what I could say and
how language is [ __ ] I was like I saw
people doing that and I was like you
know man I'm too free man I'm like I
can't do this [ __ ] so I'm excited I'm
about to release my first [ __ ]
sneaker collaboration with Nike and oh
for started no three and again certain
things I can say the language and I was
like no man no I meant I was fed up at
this point I stopped selling uh some
weed around
Oh two and I had saved up money here and
then I was a kid oh man [ __ ] this I also
spent a lot of money on just stupid [ __ ]
a lot of meals everything in 2004 I
finally said you know what [ __ ] Nike I
win on my website which was a very big
sneaker website called Benoit calm and I
had no page you couldn't buy shoes you
couldn't lick his shoes it was just a
one page front and said [ __ ] Nike and
Arial block letters very big and when I
looked at the IP addresses because you
could search you know who's with your
page there are so many from Portland
Oregon like Beaverton Oregon Portland
Oregon like oh [ __ ] and then I get this
message pay ban which lets you know that
you know we're not gonna cut
relationships with you we don't want to
talk to you
[ __ ] you but at that point she was even
telling the owners of very big sneaker
stores like that they're in business n'
hey if you had been in your store and of
course is allegedly [ __ ] i know they're
saying if you get been in your store
we're gonna have to pull your nike count
so they're trying to blackballed me from
these stores I was like okay alright so
I gathered my senior collection I
started selling off small parts here and
there some of the bigger like more
generally shoes that were like two three
hundred bucks whatever
I started moving them to to Yokohama
Tokyo Japan and I decided to put an
auction up and it had to be two
different auctions
the auctions hit hit every message for
him it hit message forms I won't even
like like sneak related and the auction
starts growing on eBay I hope [ __ ] here
we go that all we knew and it was like I
started and I truly Dix has never
happened before I started what is now
called the reseller game get Gordon
Gekko style both auctions and at just
under 2.9 million dollars now because
millionaire for the first time in my
life by accident which I say it's not by
accident but I mean I didn't
intentionally do that but start the
minute of the day you know from that
point forward I knew everything I've
been doing the life meant something and
so you know I went bought a Ferrari the
immediate data check clear you know what
did that I went to [ __ ] did a bunch
of silly [ __ ] I go to restaurants to
order six drinks I'd have an iced tea
orange juice two sprite coke alcoholic
beverage another [ __ ] my appetizer
you know I finished what I can and I was
never that guy um and then uh you know
my fiancee at the time she was a
supermodel and she was like she was the
one who lost the breadwinner in our
house and she was like hey man I gotta
be honest with you you know I don't know
who the [ __ ] you are one um
you turned into a total douchebag and
this just isn't working out and I was
like [ __ ] man
I'll find another girl I ain't trippin
you know blah blah whatever she leaves
I [ __ ] up by the way I got caught
cheating on the girl she's never caught
me she knew though that was always going
on women have a great intuition and I
started much I started seeing my life
kind of spiral like down and I was a
[ __ ] man I got depressed I actually went
to go see a therapist for the first time
my life I was smoking way more way than
usual I was drinking I was even taking
pills I was being just a little reckless
and I said hey man you know what I need
to [ __ ] get some culture I need to
get a passport and see the world and do
something I've never did and I want to
do boom so I travel I think I had about
20 country
in a six-month span and I'm trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
next
and I couldn't figure it out for the
life of me I thought about opening up a
business I wasn't open a barber shop
that was like go there buy some dope
white tees you can buy some other cool
clothes some trinkets all the cool [ __ ]
that hip-hop people like boom by the
town there it is and I was like you know
man that's a hit I know I hate I was not
gonna ever work in food because I worked
at Burger King when I was in high school
I worked at Subway I hate any kind of
food business is just a nightmare I
wouldn't want to invest in a restaurant
care how successful just that [ __ ] just
brought back bad memories of being like
a slave and busboy and drive through it
I was like no [ __ ] Steven on a nicer
little restaurant so I came back I had a
mentor at the time mr. carton was world
famous tattoo artist and he gave me a
lot of good advice you know and um I hit
up my cousin who had been doing jewelry
for a long time his dad my uncle had
been a jeweler there in a pretty seedy
part of south-central Lang in the hood
and the ghetto and I go sit down she
just drive and take a take a drive to
his shop and it's like you know it's the
hood I go there once a lot to get white
cheese and socks and just sometimes I
should get sneakers down there and like
you know um this is after the riots
obviously way off this 2004 and I see my
cousin has a Corvette and that was like
a nice car and he had a Corvette I have
a Ferrari but at the same time I also
have a rules Royce was weird and I
didn't want to go to sloth since in
south central in the Rolls Royce slow
you know I bought my friend's BMW idrive
down there and I seen my cousin's car
and it knows his car and it had an
iridescent paint job
so it was like green paint wasn't
chameleon like we was like dude this is
the biggest douchebag who drives his car
finance my cousin's car he tells me he's
doing brain he's lucrative business is
very good consider it and he had
proposed this to me in 97 when I got the
music business to like bring bone
thugs-n-harmony brain you know dr. Dre
anybody bring some celebrity chefs we
can get this business going so we agree
the Korean way which is just a handshake
and I said hey listen we gotta at least
try to LLC our parents have not spoke to
each other because they [ __ ] each other
over in business and they didn't do
things the right way
let's head at least have some paperwork
you know the handshake was one thing so
you know we started out
yesterday there are some conditions
let's start this business boom next
thing you know I have an insane rolodex
from the music business and being on the
nightclubs and you know whatever and uh
you know I work with Travis Barker I
work with Mariah Carey I work with the
clips
Pusha T these guys legendary hip hop
group and things start to take off my
mentor and Idol in the games guy named
Jacob the jeweler Jacob around but Jacob
hood co and Jacob went to jail for money
laundry and when he went to jail don't
want to talk to him so I had to get in
with Diddy and these other big
celebrities and so now everyone
this guy had Childers making millions
upon millions they all start shifting
slowly my way but it also opened for
other New York dealership flourish as
well but that's where it started and
then you know I just went in increments
oh nine the recession hit and I realized
I was like wow I've never seen nothing
like it my parents have never seen a
recession like that in their lives oh
nine it's getting really bad and I said
I need to figure something out because
I'm about to quit jewelry this is
ridiculous
so I had some of the name people on
MySpace know me I was popular enough and
I started creating jewelry that wasn't
twenty-five fifty sixty thousand dollars
and I started making jewelry that was a
thousand to two thousand three thousand
maddox I started making these pieces and
it was a little more it was kind of like
style to wear like little classy diamond
chains just be like Major League
Baseball I'll keep it you know hip-hop
and um that did pretty well I met my
wife and oh nine and then uh you know we
got together and she became like a
good-luck talk to me and things started
turning around and even parts 2010 think
we're doing bad I started to do really
well like in February and next thing you
know I just take my marketing never had
I've never had a real agent anything
else you know I get a small reality show
later on fuse Network and they done the
shows down put them on Google which is
YouTube and you know just each year I
just took it to another level and then
you know I can't tell you how many
rappers have set my name in a song and
then you know there's hit songs things
like that and then I incorporated my
side brand been bought in the chain
and you know I just had I had money
coming in from different directions from
from street wear jewelry from
appearances and I finally like it took
so long in life I mean no I was
represented by W and me I had CAA before
that that's the at record they tried to
get into business they never understand
the influencer marketing thing they're
getting it now but one I hate that word
influencer I [ __ ] can't stand that
works I've too much talent and there's
too much that I do for me to be called
that so I finally just recently gotten
with a real big agency and they've taken
it to a whole different level that
partnership Snickers with Moet Hennessy
um k-swiss Puma like you know just a
bunch of things I'm starting to get
things and even though I'm not for
everyone I'm a very brash I'm a very
foul mouth I'm you know I I'm very
outspoken you know I'm not for every
company you know but but we started to
find the companies that can look past
that and I've been okay I just obviously
can't say [ __ ] Trump and things like
that like so freely I don't talk about
religion and things like that but that's
what we are today and you know Anna
Geist yeah for sure
so let's go back to the aftermath days I
think a lot of people just like that's
the time of a hip hop where everyone was
like man that was the golden era was
when all that was going on what is like
the number one member you have of
working there with Dre and kind of all
the work that they were doing the number
one memory was I had an eagle out of
control I've never changed I think my
mom has said this last year she said you
never changed if anything you've
polished some areas you know you always
had confidence and money never changed
you it enhanced you know certain things
about you but that period your life you
were definitely a piece of [ __ ] my mom
saying this right she was very proud of
me but at the same time like you know
like this was embarrassing because you
know Koreans you know they want you to
be a doctor lawyer blah blah I'm like
look man that's like that's not the
worst job to be an ami not friends I
mean my attorney in my head and my
doctor great people but um ego out of
control I'm making 100
a year and the I'm starting to see
checks like I wasn't getting this $55 a
month paycheck that's you know after
taxes everything else blah blah whatever
you paid tracks and things I was getting
bonuses and points and things like that
you know now remembered ret Dre wrote me
a really big check I've never had a
check like I've never had a six-figure
check in my entire life
and he pulls me to the side and he says
a man making a million dollars is easy
keeping it is not and I was like man
make a million I thought even then I'm
24 I thought once you become a
millionaire you stand doing it I didn't
know you know I you know why would I
know
so pulls me aside and he bought everyone
an expedition this was like the hottest
this was the hottest SUV out and there
was a ton people but he bought like you
know the eight guys expeditions and he
bought like three or four girls
explorers that work in the company and I
was like yellow dough and everyone got
their checks lot of these guys make more
money because they had points their
producers and their artists and stuff
but you know it pulls me to the side he
was what he can do with the money and
I'm like why are you asking me that's
[ __ ] up did you how did you ask them
did you ask butter did you ask Mellon to
ask Chris like you know white white
white [ __ ] me and you because you're
my Asian man you know what I think you
have more potential you know like what
are you gonna do them I don't know man
you know I mean I've never had money
before you know what I'm gonna do like I
want to get her Sachi show you those
okay get over Saachi shirt we're gonna
do it
I don't know why cuz man look at man
don't be an n-word and I was like what
and I was like man okay whatever you
know it was I really wasn't paying
attention I was focused on going to the
BMW dealership century west BMW it was
in the back of my mind I just had to go
and he was like man listen man just be
smart no okay fine I go straight to
century West BMW I go buy an m3 left
there I was there an hour and a half to
a paper but I left there I go to this
play called juniors jewelers
Sherman Oaks and I buy a Rolex with
diamonds in it I come back to the studio
because the studio our hours are
different drill work till 3:00 4:00 in
the morning to him you know so I go back
to aftermath studios and I pull up in
the car and everything else I don't say
anything someone's gonna be mad right
the dude who runs a studio it's also
drains like right-hand man he tells me
what's going on a man this one here this
this and we have a ton of security
because you can't just go in there we
like are the same thing so it starts
going around the studio a man been bald
you'll have it then yeah you know been
been hanging been calling man yo she
bought this pink tub ja she got chrome
windows man just a bus oh man just
[ __ ] man when I painted this and
so from what I heard Dre got up like
literally out of his seat they said he
got a beat is to being made like he's
making a beat like you say you felt like
halfway into the making of a song stops
it walks out of Studio B walks into the
kitchen I'm making a throws beef
sandwich with all this extra man
syndrome blah blah I was like the
repartee goes oh you having a nice
sandwich
I was like man and he goes so what's up
man would you do today I was like oh man
you know I was kind never had a roll
that's before you know so like you know
boom and he goes oh nice watch man it's
a nice watch man you didn't buy anything
else and I was like well I mean I bought
a couple things like all you get a
Versace shirt I was like nah I'll get
one this week he goes no you don't need
to get one this week otherwise because
that's your [ __ ] black BMW out
there and chrome wheels and everything
else and I was like man I wanted a nice
car even those you have a nice car you
know you've got a Lexus and you have
expedition and most people at your age
don't even have two cars literally a
third one oh I'm selling the Lexus and
he goes and he didn't speak to me for
almost a month I'll supply my most
memorable moment one of the most
memorable moments and he was just
disgusted with me now the funny thing
was all that money went
swell left after meant I had no money I
was broke I did just great it's crazy
how he saw coming right but but you got
a little lessons for yourself
by the way I think I needed that kick in
the ass
yeah well that's what happens right and
then on the Nike talk forums you were
wild man I had a lot of people who tell
me when I said I was gonna do is they
like yeah you gotta talk to you about
the Nike talk for him he was going wild
about their you know um there's
moderators and admin on the on these I
don't know how how I don't think any
other message form was this crazy even
like I've been part of car message forms
for I forms everything was ever just
pooping in there and people have jokes
or whatever this was like a real
legitimate form back of the day and um I
was like the first cuz I didn't know
need to get banned but I got banned like
two or three times immediately and then
I became one of the most banned people
on that site then they IP ban me where I
had to go change internet providers to
go watch the site not even started
create name whatever it was crazy so um
I started to play nice I started
realizing I would talk [ __ ] I would
literally this is the thing I grew up in
the streets where we talk [ __ ] to each
other know what's gonna go call the
police or call the me to movement or
whatever blah blah nothing are some of
the words wrong yeah okay I get it
bagging on somebody look man the shaming
thing is just so [ __ ] ridiculous now
someone's like oh man you're fat you're
old you're washed up I'm going to come
and retaliate back and kill you again
you ain't gonna get a shot no way that's
what we did we shot [ __ ] to each other
all day long
now it's like hey man did you really
just batching that person shut the [ __ ]
up bro listen I'm not with that [ __ ]
[ __ ] man everyone's so sensitive today
and everything else but you know I mean
it was just a different thing I would
talk crazy and so um I helped a lot of
people on that site though and one day I
went this was during the time was look
one of the most famous things was I
found out that these Nike skateboard
shoes that called sb dunks we're gonna
come out and I found out early so I did
a trip all the way from Oregon down to
San Diego the entire West Coast and I
cleared out 40% of the SB stock I put
all of them in storage and didn't even
look at I think I let like 40 pairs go
for like a lot of good
so that retail I put them away I forgot
I forgot they even existed you
understand I've never been a Thai person
to save money I've never been a safe
person whatever this was like I was like
you know what he's gonna burn something
I just I just had a hunch I didn't have
like this IPO being read by God you know
but I had a hunch in an IPO sense like
this is gonna [ __ ] blow up
let me let him sure enough there wasn't
enough supply to go around it wasn't a
big release and it wasn't a big release
on purpose it was just I mean I think
did that part like a limited edition
they just it was a skateboard marketed
shoe they didn't opus do well or not and
they hear me III you know again Gordon
Gekko mentality I clear the [ __ ] out so
when I did that I posted a big picture
in my living room with all the shoes
lined up and I said yo you guys keep
posting your collections right what
about the stock room pics fam I created
a term called stock room pics it became
a rule on Nike Talk one of the new rules
cuz anyone posting stock room pitch will
be banned from this site blah blah
because it didn't do anything but it
promoted back in I mean now you're not
collecting anymore
now you're reselling you know I was a
collector you're looked upon now I'm
taking other people's who want to get
shoes and I'm selling it to them for
four or five times the price and it just
[ __ ] up the game this is the early part
now there's stock X's there's coke
there's stadium business it's like
there's so many different websites you
can buy shoes from and there's so many
reseller stores so anyways I found this
out early so the stock room picks pissed
everybody off then for all the people
that were banned
like for real throw they couldn't get
into IP address they created hood talk
which was the Nike talk hater page it
was called hater talk at first but
somehow someway we violated a bunch of
rules so they they they got to sex the
website performed banned and then it
became good talk and it was basically
there were forms in their general forum
boo then name all the moderators and
admins you think are haters and they
would photoshopped pictures of them post
their address as [ __ ] these people ever
then they had [ __ ] work could obviously
post porn and Nike talk but like there
was a foreign section then there was
joke section then there was this then
there was a rich section all you do is
roast each other like oh man this shitty
ass mustache y'all pop you still
[ __ ] wired air what's all the earpods
you why he got that cheap ass huh that's
a 47 even real loo air like it was just
bad sessions going on and it was so much
xenophobia racism every possible
homophobe it just crazy you were just
going loose on there and they're like
you know man Ben's really active on this
thing and it wasn't I just talked so
much [ __ ] on there I don't think I ever
even grew up I never even like mature
and I just acted like throughout the
entire time and then a certain point I
became really popular on the page and
people were just like young people call
me out like oh man you didn't do it [ __ ]
with your life well blog whatever but I
got my first place I bought I posted
pictures of it posted pictures of my
cars things like that and so I was like
just flexing on their heavy and people
hated it but some people were like a man
you know what he did it himself
you know he made the money himself II to
come from a rich family I mean you know
guys had these and even still this guy
bought a bunch of shoes sold them and
you know he hustled some guys that are
still doing this there's one guy who's
sitting on [ __ ] you know five six
million dollars and shoes that and part
of me is like yo bro like amazing you
stuck it out put what a [ __ ]
nightmare dog sell your [ __ ] don't do
something dick with your life
like that's all he has them you know
like with me it was like nah somethings
better than this yeah I think part of it
is when it comes all the [ __ ] talking I
grew up in a family with five boys so
that's basically the way we communicated
right you could never walk in the room
and say hey man like your clothes right
he's got to be a man you sure look
stupid
hey yeah of course talking [ __ ] and look
I'm real close on my brothers and still
to this day right he answered the phone
it's like what's up loser
I hear you on that I think part of
what's so compelling about your story
that right is everyone tries to put
labels on it oh he was a DJ he did you
know the shoes he's a jeweler all stuff
but at the end of the day like your
entire story every stop along the ways
you're just an entrepreneur right it was
just constantly pursuing how do I do
something that creates value and leads
to revenue or or income now you're good
and so maybe talk a little bit about
just like at what point did you realize
like I'm actually conducting business
here right I'm actually an entrepreneur
it's not just me with like a bunch of
side hustles like that there's a
structure to this and I can do this in
any industry right whether it's DJing
whether it's with shoes whether it's
with jewelry like it's the same thing
over and over again just in different
industries and creating value so what
happened was I've never worked in
anything I didn't actually have an
interest in people have a hard time
becoming successful in one career like
you said right on as successful I was
successful in three careers okay and one
of those careers being to side careers
you know um this how it goes
I never had a wealth manager or a CPA to
advise me on how to incorporate myself
and do things like that I was like oh my
[ __ ] something told me this you know
a long time ago like I just [ __ ] off
you know like one it was saving me
enormous amount of money on taxes and
whatever things like that but um from
music early on I saw where I missed
opportunities to make money I could have
sold mixtapes here boom well if I sold
5000 mixtapes well it cost me nothing
but my labor and some basic cost boom
okay there's also the cost to buy
cassettes that a user of mixtape right
now that's like some [ __ ] we're
talking about real mix tapes that were
like you know like they were blended
through and there was this and that then
people elevated it and then all of a
sudden they call it mixtape it's part of
a record label it's like not a mixtape
it's like songs is also it was just
different so anyway it's going on I
realized that missed opportunities I had
as a record executive when I became a
solo DJ I started to understand alright
how important it is to market myself so
if you remember that movie American Pie
is that was called I forgot the dude's
name was but he told that one chick
natasha Lyonne I think so tell everybody
he had a really big penis or something
Ryan it was like a boom it was like a
rumor
like in a way I was telling people oh
you know man
yeah you know I'm getting paid like five
600 dollars a night 500 was definitely
was Mark Ronson nobody was getting paid
that much of a nightclub back then in
the 90s and like I was telling people
yeah man you know his crazy man wanted
Paris next week to go DJ this this and
this and I was making up these stories
but I was doing it because I had no
other way to promote myself and people
were like you know what and it was like
it's Instagram that oh where's the
pictures at there's no [ __ ] cameras
back there like you they barely had the
disposable camera back there but no one
had no one really carried you up
you had like guys who had a real
professional photo but it was like no it
wasn't that common to have to take
pictures of your other me sometimes yeah
but me it just was I know I'm Asian
people like all the cameras that was a
big joke back in the 80s the 90s and 70s
you know Japanese people always have
cameras right well anyways I didn't have
work so I started marketing and I
developed this folklore of Ben Butler
being bigger than he was it landed me a
job in Vegas at the Hard Rock Hotel
Casino I am getting a billboard there
that start you know started with and I
started taking out ads in newspapers the
LA Weekly and small that's like a bull
you know been bars doing missus people
be a dragonfly here and I started to
realize that was good then the sneaker
thing was part of my DJ cuz I was DJing
I was selling weed the weed money that
was cached was going into sneakers the
sneakers when they got sold or where
they did I've watched the cash at that
point they weren't checking [ __ ] like
that back in the day eBay wasn't even
[ __ ] charging your feet people in
charge of things now paintballs making
sure the taxes are done you know that
mean like they're hitting you they're
recording everything it wasn't like that
back then you know even on eBay eBay had
a feature where you were able to look
let's say for instance I'm like I want
to see what pop is buying today
oh [ __ ] pop off some KY jelly he bought
two pairs of Nikes there's specific
things I could see everything you bought
I could see the things we even watch and
it was crazy a super you know like
invasive of your privacy but I was able
to like you know just I understood like
alright I got this little thing here
okay let's make some t-shirts and I'm
gonna say they're limited
I only made a hundred nobody [ __ ]
knew I made 500 whatever it was and we
did it and they sold out and so that was
another hustle and then I created a crew
airmax crew this is the sneaker called
the air max but then there's the term
Mac which is sort of like a pimp mi CK
so I called ourselves to air max crew so
we were like the Nike pit crew right it
was me this guy named DJ ha Messiah who
was very famous he was a group called
Sugar Ray an enormous rock band pop band
and then DJ an rest in peace who was my
boy and we had an honorary member who no
one even knows is his name is domain e
he owned
flight club he started flying but this
time was called vintage chicks you know
he stole his company for 60 million
dollars it's a lot of money so we had
this crew I was doing appearances I was
able to market myself without a manager
I had an email address that was my
acting manager no one ever met this
person he's like Charlie from [ __ ]
Charlie's Angels right and I was just
able to to to you know keep elevating
myself but as basketball happened I told
you I wish I had another year was out of
the year this where I'm at you know I
wasn't a rapper or certain things were
like you know after you turn 30 you're
like washed-up and want to hear your
music getting we're not talking about
drugs and guns anymore and blah blah
it's harder as you get older to be a
rapper to take credible stay relevant so
you know I never looked at it the
entrepreneur side until I sold my
collection and I realized holy [ __ ] I
couldn't do this a long time ago and not
have a sell an entire bulk I could have
did this in a different way but I
understood at that point anything I'm
passionate about I'm going to find a way
to make money so when I started the
jewelry business even that I said we got
to create a separate name we have
friends certainly on MySpace to promote
it and then we have the traditional
stuff we can put flyers I can do certain
things or whatever I can start marketing
and putting on celebrities of course
that's the best motion whatever and I
started realizing okay we're big we got
so big that I can co my company which
stands for internally flawless and
company internally flawless is
technically the best diamond you could
possibly get in the world
our company was really called I see
fresh ink Oh honest EEE and we were
using the IC logo like its i see i see
ee it's all melted with ice and
everything and then we had fresh and a
engraver spot was like the Cash Money
font and I have them together and
putting this out there
I see the the slushie corporation sees
that when you google I see we were
coming up in the top five they want to
own the top 20 on Google so they send a
cease-and-desist to us because they're
saying that we're confusing people
because we're talking about ice and
stuff like well ice as a [ __ ] is a
slang for diamonds you know the mean
slang for jewelry and they're like okay
we don't care that happens boom we have
to restructure and at that point I said
oh man look you want to get big okay
Tiffany and coda to sell t-shirts they
don't need to they have the turquoise
box that's their marketing thing right
what do we have all right we need to go
out here and market this [ __ ] so we're
making plastic pieces I started making
t-shirts unless that became I was making
enough side [ __ ] that wasn't jewelry
well technically the plastic things were
t-shirts that was taking care of our
entire payroll that hustle so everything
else balances cream on the top you know
I'm saying it's [ __ ] I see literally
pun intended right so I um I started to
realize hey man you know I think all
this dope but what about Ben baller the
brand so I just started to market myself
after Oh 8 and you know it just every
you know five years or so leave unless I
elevate what I'm doing when I got into
the cabinet space you know I came at it
let's see what happens boom you know out
there whatever there's people who have a
lot more followers of me I explain I
don't know if they're fake or not their
engagement isn't the same you don't have
the same following when I did my
television show these people did a
professional they did professional
analytics of what my demographic was you
know like a man look man for someone
your age you know they're gonna have
someone strong in their age group they
might have a little bit of people above
the middle go get small you have fun
twelve sixteen year olds you have an 18
to 24 you have the 24 to 32 you get the
32 to 40 you even had 60 year olds I had
such a wide audience that I was like
holy [ __ ]
this is a good thing so you know I
didn't have to study my market anymore
and I just put I said hey look at anyone
21 and over I got this new vape pen you
know it was early on no module debate I
was against cannabis thankful I was I
want to be fine it I didn't want to be
some mediocre [ __ ] I was trying to be
the Walmart elite I wanted to be the
Apple so I said you know what I did gold
platinum and rose gold those are the
three colors they made available I had
12 strains put them out there
next thing I know I get in order 400,000
pens and my partners will begin the
cannabis base to like holy [ __ ] man all
right man this is exactly what we
thought would happen
I didn't invest a single dollar in the
company and I was able to get 40% of the
company but 30 and 30 but them together
they had a majority share you know that
my voice whatever bottom line is it
became insanely lucrative the cameras
base became big and again I was like yo
we got to do merch we got to do hats
this dismiss and I gave a ton away um
and you know I was very passionate about
I started doing in-store appearances all
throughout California and there be three
hundred to a thousand people lining
outside and every time I'm like bro if
you told me even ten years ago people
would line up to meet me there's a
stupidest thing though I can't these POS
what I'm eating is silly and you know
meeting these people and you know it's
just it's just been really really good
it didn't get bad until the pandemic
happened one the technology appends that
I use for our cannabis business is built
in based in China's called seaso
technology of course so that [ __ ] got
stopped and obviously there was people
who are complaining about vaping debts
now look I've never said Kobe was was
that was a hoax I've been a big advocate
on spreading the awareness for a long
time the vape thing definitely hooks yes
people are getting sick guess what they
were smoking things with pesticides they
forget to say that they're just thinking
all pens are very poor job on the
media's part because there are people
out there that are doing a good job and
putting out good product there's
pesticide free and listen
the BCC which is like the IRS FDA of
cannabis and you know we're following
the rules it just stuck to killed our
business a little bit but I was able to
work around that and I always am one
door closes and I could be in an all
cement room okay I'm going to [ __ ]
laser saw a door and open that [ __ ] you
know I'm gonna figure out a way to do
something always but um you know it's
I've always figured out a way to to come
up now in the pandemic were in a very
special space I could have made a lot of
money selling masks and doing certain
things
I felt morally ethically it was wrong
for me to benefit off this even if i
donated [ __ ] of money and just felt
that's just ending it that's not it man
I've seen people make a ton of money
sine-theta Anna said look man there's
got to be another way you people don't
realize look I didn't talk about that
until like you know a month ago but
right now we're at what 26 million
people have no jobs or the 30 I don't
know the exact number but what I'm
getting at is I truly feel like okay
fine open the economy back up not New
York but open it back up
I did a pulled the other day 89 percent
of people said we know no [ __ ] store
to sit at me some restaurant to sit down
to eat no [ __ ] movie theater I'm not
gonna get it they're scared to whatever
and they have every reason to be
especially people like me myself you
know I'm I'm a smoker I [ __ ] I'm 25
pounds overweight you know my son has a
very very high chance of dying from it
so with that said this shit's gonna be
bad and the economy will get worse worse
and worse and I feel terrible if I
accepted money from so buying certain
things so it's like certain things where
I feel like they bring down you you know
of whatever it may be I have a
collaboration with tops baseball cards I
had a big you know I was a big baseball
card collector when I was a kid and
there was a really really big episode of
Gary Vee that he did about baseball
cards I've never followed Gary Vee heard
his name a bunch times we had mutual
friends I always felt like okay what's
up with this dude whatever I don't know
listen to the episode he talked about
baseball cards and when you're talking
about investments in the 2000 it was
like the most that was the best you know
option I didn't know so these baseball
cards are selling really well my podcast
by keeping it real informing people now
that obviously people realize later holy
[ __ ] Ben was right and we all thought he
was a [ __ ] idiot this [ __ ] guy
gave us quite information like you know
like we should probably you know like
give do dis flowers and with that said
traffic went up with that obviously
sponsorship money came up and I started
generating real money you know more than
six figures now we're we're holy [ __ ]
never in a million years my income from
jewelry has stopped my custom jewelry is
there and it's this but I don't consider
that like I don't look at it like oh
well I got money here that's not how it
goes I need to have a positive on every
aspect of every business my cannabis has
gone down because we're not essential
cuts of eight now it builds my flower
company which we haven't launched yet
that was being launched in March so
[ __ ] up I have three enormous
collaborations takashi murakami probably
one of the greatest biggest living
contemporary artists on earth and like
we made a lot of money then i had you
know potentially 1.7 million dollars to
make with him that got canceled for us a
year because one that was in hong kong
what is it New York and other ones in
Japan and these these collaborations
aren't just gonna happen it can't or
they have to be I don't know how they
can't happen now um I had a big show I
was doing so a lot of my money it
stopped so even though podcast is doing
want everything else
I'm not considered yeah you should be
blessed we should be lucky you know what
I would I don't read very much but Phil
Jackson had said in this book if you
have no expectations you'll never be
disappointed
[ __ ] that bro I demand my life you know
I'm saying Koreans and Italians have a
lot of passion you know we talked about
me angry have you know how angry issues
were aggressive people and because my
retail dream business sucks the custom
ones going on right that I might not sin
but the Canada sucks whatever so it's
like I don't look at it like it is a
blessing but at the same time I'm like
alright how do I do this and figure this
out because it's going to get worse and
worse how many people gonna go why about
a $25,000 bracelet in three or four
months you know like even the 1% or the
point zero zero one percent they're not
spending like that you know I see the
car inside the car to see taking things
like that so I'm just in a very unique
space right now where
last year late last year I thought that
we're gonna have a recession so I've
been saving for that and I've been
worried about that so I scaled back on a
lot
I haven't scaled back on my cell phones
we have six up when it comes to everyone
my kids are the cellphone why cuz I'm a
[ __ ] idiot so I got rid of their cell
phone account at school I had an every
single channel on DirecTV and I had like
so many different extra boxes like wait
okay one we don't need twelve
televisions in the house we have twelve
last gets [ __ ] stupid okay so we need
to figure that but but I basically had
an overhead of seventy one thousand
dollars a month of my bills before I ate
a chicken sandwich that was my bills
that includes my kids food not my
personal whatever I got that down to 47
last month and I just got it two days
ago down a 35,000 month now that means
I've cut my entire overhead 50% and I'm
still technically living the same
lifestyle I liveth and I'm just trying
to figure that out as we go venture into
into into the new waters I have to use
my entrepreneur skills of how I can do
this without and some people I
understand at this point if you're
[ __ ] up you're unemployed whatever and
you're hustling as long as you're not
stealing or you're like selling [ __ ]
what's a hydroxy call or me whatever or
[ __ ] putting you know disinfected in
your arms or [ __ ] like that as long
as you're not hurting anybody when
you're out there hustling hey man I
can't be mad at you right because people
have to feed their kids whatever so with
that said I think I've been pushing my
podcast it's the thing I enjoy the most
out of anything that I've been doing I
think I've been meant to talk [ __ ] you
know and I'll let you know what I talk
so much [ __ ] I should talking to a
[ __ ] microphone and and and you know
put it out there became popular it's
doing well it's something I can do it
till I'm 78 years or 60 years old so
I've been focusing on that now with the
podcast
okay yes your sponsor money here and
there how do we take to another level
well believe it or not and this happened
before before the pandemic started
my birthday is January 27th someone gave
me a really small ball of sanitizer I'm
a germaphobe for the last two or three
years I've always carried small ones
like an ounce but I saw this half ounce
eyes are really small and I was like ah
it's really cool
I contacted that company in January and
I was like you know what I want to make
Ben baller did the chain sanitizers for
my podcast i order it and then this [ __ ]
happens so as the bottles are being
finished boom they're ready to go out
they hit me and say hey listen we can't
send you your sanitizer bottles because
you know we have millions of gallons of
sanitizer we have to fill orders in boom
so I find a guy who kind of finally do
it so I mean I'm not gonna make a profit
I'm sorry I'm not going to sell it for
$10 20 lifeline whatever but if I sell
my sanitizers at a 1/2 an ounce to ounce
size for 3 or 4 dollars which would be
anything I'm just competing against
other companies what do people do after
that [ __ ] it that's their problem right
and I just figured out other ways where
I can do things and not [ __ ] people up
because it can bring value to them like
my Ben bar the chain appliance a
collection like I have a money counter I
have a gold back concealer eye things
like that those items sold out in 8
seconds for a hundred fifty to two
hundred dollars the resale value of the
negative 800 to 1200 so the things that
I'm selling are bringing by the people
my baseball cards they're $19 for the
regular ones the artist boosts or $99
$99 ones one for a thousand one week
after the regular cards want for under
50 so it's like look man as I've said
everyone hates on old people they think
the old people hate on young people I
just troll out and talk a lot of [ __ ] I
don't want to respect for young people
and I've always been attracted and I
gravitated towards younger people
because they have very cool innovative
ideas and things I don't steal them I
just you know like I'm like okay how do
we enhance this how do we magnify this
how do you monetize while these people
are out there that early 30s I feel like
they're washed up or whatever I'm still
relevant and becoming more relevant at
47 you know and as I get older so it's
like I'm just I've never been this busy
I've never stayed put in my entire life
in 20 years I would stay put you know I
took 118 Flags last year I went on some
early flights in January I did
a mandatory one in February and I cancel
everything after that because of my
family but now that I've been staying
put for 60 days right I'm like holy [ __ ]
this is crazy
I've spent so much more time with my
kids even though I'm very hands-on with
my family and my three kids there's
different types of time I'm learning
things about my children I've never knew
about and I'm spending time but at the
same time now my life is you know the
principal of the school she's the head
teacher I'm the [ __ ] vice principal
of school I'm also a teacher
we have parent-teacher conferences with
each other and we get in arguments and
it's like crazy because no it's it's
difficult cuz our kids have so much
homework so with that said that among
Xoom amongst my podcast and taking a lot
of Meads for content I've never been
busier it's crazy I'm so [ __ ] busy
with this so you know I don't know if
that addresses the entrepreneur thing
but I've used that to navigate myself
through these through these in it and
it's hell yeah well I think part of like
you know as as people have kind of
gotten to know you and you've been
really public and talked about podcasts
is that first of all you got to make the
motto of the podcast I was born to talk
[ __ ] I'm asking all time motto right
there but but as part of like being an
innovator and all the innovation that
you've done you gotta tell the story
about the 10 million dollar Saudi rig
whatever you could say about it I think
that was like the one piece of jewelry
that you've made the people are like hey
we got to hear whatever story he's got
there that he can tell what's behind
that piece so with that story it's like
no now I'm doing everything right now I
think had I not made jewelry for Michael
Jackson like the Sultan of Brunei dr.
Phil people who are like very outside my
hip-hop demographic clients um I get a
call from somebody and every time you go
out to the nightclubs and stuff in the
late 2000s to the early 2010 11 to 12
this
you know sappy dudes air guy he come
around in the sickest Lamborghinis I'm
talking about like super cars coming in
the hypercar hypercars technically
anything about I think a million dollars
right and he have a security guard so I
think when he drive like a regular
clothes you wear his his his outfit
which is with you know with with the um
him I can't think of the word the with
the headdress yeah but what anyways um
not the turbine turns right anyways yeah
the whole thing and I finally found his
Instagram page I never pushed Giuliana
and I think he always do what I did and
when I saw the pager so my point on the
a man which nobody to buy and stuff I
bet you do buy in 2008 but I never like
you know and I've shown this picture of
my boy wearing on traditional clothes
when he's in LA he's not wearing that
plus she doesn't like big pictures being
taken him so no one ever to take
pictures so take pictures of the car but
he's not part of their culture they're
not supposed to be popping I'll be out
there boom so I didn't know he was a
prince I had to find out you know
through his Instagram page and how I
found out was the head bear you know
it's like red white head bear I didn't
know that there was like patterns in it
and when you have a pattern in it those
patterns mean something it can be
regular - regular just silly whatever
but if you see it a certain way
immediately anybody in Abu Dhabi Saudi
or like you know whoever does say that
police chief he's well fam I'm my boy he
knows that immediately and then he goes
he'll do me a favor man it goes you've
got car pictures on his page was okay
got some crap pictures so I show a
picture of a Range Rover and a
rolls-royce and he goes bad man he has a
single-digit license plate and he knows
when you have a single did it twist to
it even slightly two or three digit you
weren't even a regular even a police or
civilian anyone a car you could be rich
no Mercedes Benz or Rolls Royce you have
to stay at least 100 feet back from that
car even police have to say that they're
not allowed not allowed to get Nicks
that car anything else they have
different different rules out there
they're royalty King right
trash all that [ __ ] one day the guy who
always is his liaison for LA was like a
man
he's needed married I'm a cool man dope
was gonna happen [ __ ]
you know billion dollar wedding is gonna
be you know traditional and he needs a
backup great what does that mean he goes
well cartier is making his ring and I
was like of course they are what do you
want me for you don't saying this shit's
like ridiculous he goes well I mean you
know you're big and you know respects
you and you know he thinks you're pretty
cool and you do for all these people he
can't tell his mom I mean like so he
said bought people but or his family but
you know that's what he does on his
personal time and you know he sees what
you're making could you make something
really cool for his wife-to-be knows
like yeah man I was like in my head I
might do this [ __ ] gonna spend
too many dollars doesn't be like three
million dollars be my you know it's
crazy
and I'm a joy for a million to blamin he
hits me with a stone that he wants and I
like to think I'm the biggest thing in
the world right and then you go to these
jewelry trade shows then you realize how
ok yes I'm the biggest popular person
but when it comes to significance in the
dynamic game I am so insignificant
because people have these boots that
have 30 40 60 million dollars of
diamonds and there's like not that many
diamonds then you're like holy [ __ ] you
know like the most expensive thing in my
store any given moment might be a
quarter million or four thousand
whatever do these people have a twin
million dollar diamond here 30 million
here 1760 like their shitty [ __ ] is like
1.6 million like the little [ __ ] so
I reach out to somebody and I say hey
man I'm looking for this stone here it's
a pink diamond and I need to get this I
need this color this everything and the
only thing that they wanted was they
didn't want me to specifically say what
it was because it goes chin it could
kind of genetically go back to the
person whatever and I could say princess
everything else is just in one way or
whatever so going on I hit my cousin up
because he's the part of the backend
that deals with the diamond dealers and
we text and he goes alright so he calls
me and I'm like what's up man then he
goes it's a joke or did you for did you
did you add an extra number on the back
end it was a
whereas how big the diamond is I was
like no bro it's both numbers that's the
number and he goes who the [ __ ] is it
and I says it's the prince and he goes
holy [ __ ]
okay let's try to forget us out so we
hit up our diamond dealer who was
goddess everything like ever looking for
this stone and the guy goes get the [ __ ]
out of here I was like no leave that
stone so now I became like a [ __ ] a
whole mission to find the stone um even
the big places like like graph Harry
Winston Bank left they have a hard time
finding the stone the size of this this
thing anyways I end up finding it I had
to give somebody a million dollars to
get the diamond not come but they got a
million for finding the diamond do you
understand what I'm trying to say to you
right so my cost on the stone which he
understands where a baby was six and a
half million so you know I made two and
a half million dollar profit just off
that ring and it was fun crazy and just
my flight there which was a [ __ ]
worst flight ever had it was right Ted
second worst flight I've had my entire
life flew private private is cool you're
flying the [ __ ] if you got a really big
like jumbo jet I go to New York private
it's not bad if you're like in a small G
for a bit
fine to like Vegas you know LA the
Seattle not bad flying to [ __ ] Saudi
Arabia is not pulling that [ __ ]
like it was terrible
refueling everything scary [ __ ] I get
there um and I delivered a stone and at
that point meet his mom I'd meet the
king I mean the Sheik you know and meet
them they'll see everything boom and
they're like wow this is a beautiful
stone mind you it's [ __ ] 90 something
threes outside I'm dying I can't cover
my tattoos anymore you know I'm like
this is crazy
my head is shaped clean I made sure I
everything else my earrings everything I
was wearing was super classy it's just I
had a [ __ ] button-down shirt on
I can't do oh don't take it if you want
to really see the don't take your shirt
off you know I mean cuz I'm like [ __ ]
you know I'm like all the way through is
that don't house are his dad pulls me
aside as I came in I really appreciate
it you know what this is amazing you
know leave your information I was like
well she has everything you know and so
the 10 million dollar ring was cool he
spent 10 million dollars in a year with
me just on gifts for his his his family
members and [ __ ] like that so it led to
a whole different you know thing when I
go to Dubai now and I was there two
times last year was there you know
couple times before that I enter a
restaurant let's say for it to Zooma
zoom was one of them it's like I think
zoom was bad in Dublin was like be on
high-end sushi place and I'll be at Zuma
and Dubai and I'll order 11 her daughter
the food with like another person
whatever and then no bill will come and
they just knew and they've taken care of
it I'm going to Cipriani and Dubai which
is much nicer than the original Cipriani
one either 42nd or the one in uh you
know and Soho it's crazy anywhere I go
out there it's like I have carte blanche
it's so amazing it's just like a it was
it was it was a dope thing you know and
to him that's nothing like when this guy
shows me his watches he'll show me
watches I can even show John Mayer but
see this before it goes honestly I
haven't but remember I even get one of
the one custom bespoke watches made by
Patek Phillipe or by Rolex these dudes
are getting like and it's notorious for
studies and like even some of the stuff
they have some of the Gucci things they
have they were made by Gucci for them
and I'm like holy [ __ ] this was a
[ __ ] amazing thing being in the right
place at the right time you know being
able but if I didn't find that guy I
mean he was gonna get it from somebody
else probably he'd have to that's what
she wanted and on top of that um I would
never bet his dad you know so and I mean
it was a beautiful situation that yeah
it's pretty cool to see how just kind of
be in the right place right time leads
to one thing and then you do a good job
right do something that they think is
not possible they see you know it rolls
into a whole other part of the business
but that's kind of the whole whole thing
of being an entrepreneur right
sure what what uh what are you most
excited about once we get out of
coronavirus stuff what's the kind of the
things that you're looking forward to
most as you kind of keep building this
Empire of yours as crazy as it sounds I
feel like I've probably done I think
there's a couple goals I haven't hated
my life and a couple of those goals were
like you know I had aspirations really
ought to be a billionaire and then I
realized like yo man it's gonna happen
by a fluke or something from - I'm not
trying to be too smart anymore let me
[ __ ] focus on what I mean sport I'm
gonna try to [ __ ] create the next blue
brain I just you know and there's a lot
of composers it's a city here it's like
listen to demo tapes right when I was at
ANR it's like yeah I got this group here
I got this idea everyone has enough idea
everyone has this someone has this
that's like you know man
I have to I have you know I have enough
wealth to where I couldn't retire and
maintain the lifestyle I have but I have
a lot and and because I want my kids to
be set up but my thing is I'm excited
about showing my kids the world right
with this pandemic now all three of my
kids aren't going back to school
friendlies two or three years so now
which never in a million years did I
ever think this is gonna happen they're
gonna have to be home school now until
something happens to where my son
doesn't have that risk if my son didn't
have the risk I wouldn't even give a
[ __ ]
I mean I'd be worried about me but I'm
very careful as it is but because his
situation and my mom who's old and
everything else that's it I just have to
be very careful so with that said you
know I want my kids to they all have
passports I'm looking for at most two
traveling I want to show them all
through Europe I want to I can't wait
but the thing is again this is a global
pandemic this is not a you know it so
it's difficult I miss being in my
apartment in San Francisco looking over
the [ __ ] skyline and looking at you
don't be here and having my little
[ __ ] private time to think and think
about this and whatever in like I mean I
have 12 custom chains that are backed up
right now that you know who knows I'm
gonna finish them but um I'm excited
from my fur for fatherhood you know I
always say that I tell people I'm a
husband and father before him for
anything else in life before
entrepreneur you know that's why I
waited so late like to have
kids you know like I was talking about
Boyd flowers - I talked to you - that
it's just like [ __ ] Manny
he just finalized gonna be a grandfather
and he's two years younger than me and
it's just like a lot of my friends kids
are in high school whatever and my
oldest is seven half years old so it's
like I just started late but I started
late because I want to be able to
provide for my kids now with that said
you know I am working less but I'm
working smarter and but I'm still
working a lot it's just you know some I
don't have so much tedious [ __ ] I have
to do but but but again I mean I know it
sounds silly but I'm looking forward to
getting on a [ __ ] plane and getting
the [ __ ] I'm going a little crazy you
know
and even though I'm telling people stay
at home it's like trusting them if I
didn't have a big home um you know and I
tell people look this ain't a decayed
thing to say I'd rather tell you what it
is and what's on my mind that you think
bad guys understand [ __ ] you zero
dollars is zero dollars when I was broke
and homeless that's zero dollars I'm
nothing else you know you have a phone
you can mush it you're entitled go [ __ ]
yourself I don't know what such you just
lost your job I'm sorry live in a
[ __ ] 800 square foot apartment you
know man I earned all this this is you
know the mean like I don't feel bad at
all I never what ever you ever make me
try to you know shame me for working
hard 1 5 my family I prepared to this
this was all planned so we're here now
and with that said you know I just can't
wait to you know show my kids sports and
things like that or like you know and do
it on a bigger level just but I do want
to get out of the house I'm excited
about my podcast I'm excited at you know
meeting more people even though I want
to meet anybody I want to meet people to
talk to because you know I've been an
enormous fan of Mike Tyson and you know
there was like this there was a rumor
going around he's like always not very
smart and he talks like this that
whatever
mike is actually [ __ ] brilliant he is
so insane the stories now that podcast
is there his stories of what he's done
is I'm like I'm blown away and um you
know there's a lot of people out there
that I want to reach out to whether it
be even I'm not a big fan of Tony
Robbins but I'd love to get him on the
show and talk to about things and you
know even Mark Cuban I don't know marks
you when the dogs for the championship
mark used to party with us these
and he was like he was a gangster I was
like yo mark is cool this [ __ ] um but
the podcast is about something suddenly
but I'm excited for that you know I'm
excited to just [ __ ] I'm excited to to
do more stay pudding you know and but I
am excited obviously to get on the
[ __ ] plane I do want to go somewhere
I do want to go to an island I do want
to go to the beach Oh at least Cabo
shit's two hours away but I do want to
get [ __ ] out of house but you know I
also want to go back to work one of the
beautiful things about my podcast setup
is it's professional but it's still very
portable so I can record a lot of my
shows in the hotel room I can do this
this and this and you know that's that's
I know it sounds boring but but uh you
know I just want I just wanted to you
know extend on my travel [ __ ]
look I think that's a great life to live
I got two questions to uh to wrap up
with and he get asked me one to end it
what's the best or most important book
you've ever read I know you say you
don't read that much but what's the one
book that you're like damn that everyone
should go read this it's it's completely
specific and it's really crazy it's a
book call everything you want to know
about the music business whether
everyone or whatever it's today in 2020
ninety percent of these kids that are
signing deals under the age from 17 or
younger or ones they're 22 or deals 90%
of them it doesn't matter if you have a
good attorney the attorney your best
interest amount of how cool you are with
them do you know these deals are
structured for you to fail now people
are making more money because there's
360 deals right which is crazy
never in a million years in the 90s
could you could you [ __ ] ever ask an
artist yup your merch or you're touring
money like no you give up album sales
you know I'm saying like boom like you
know there's certain things you do that
book is the general basic of everything
you should know it's more than even
records ecute is no intelligent
everything about the business the fine
print and everything once you understand
that you will truly understand how not
to [ __ ] yourself and
that point after finishing that book two
or three times every situation you go
into and you fail in you purposely
failed it you want to go in there and
[ __ ] up your business because someone
threw a check for $500,000 not realizing
that there's 7 million on the back end
but you needed that money right then and
there you couldn't survive without that
money because you had to post a watch or
a car on Instagram to look like you were
doing ok but yet there was other ways to
flex if you had some patience that mean
other things there's other deals that
people sign because they didn't want to
shop around the first deal came around
but that book it's by Kashif cushy
there's other people my boy Clinton
sparks just put out a game a book about
the record business I didn't read it and
he's my friend and I don't want to say
anything bad but I don't know how in
depth this this book is super in-depth
and the reason why it was important to
me was because doing deals in life you
have an attorney
you know never 2 million years I think I
have an attorney on retainer and people
like why like when I got NDA's to a
meeting suit
3 I have other [ __ ] and I have you know
contra sending leg because I don't
understand English on and people that
they're not written in English so I'm
like Jesus Christ I don't mean English
I'm saying you know the terminology and
everything and some of these things so
basically that book changed the way I
look because you look at somebody who
has a lemonade stand and I don't mean
that verbal I'm saying like a
mom-and-pop or limits that they don't
understand how much more they can
enhance that business because they have
no you know they're just like what it is
why go in there for you if you do it for
hobby you know what you're gonna open a
store you know your wife is but you know
you're you're rich and you're like I'll
give my wife's I'm gonna do cuz she's at
home and you see how moms look crazy all
right
why do that I mean happiness is one
thing sure but why do that and take a
loss or take an allergy for certain
things you know there's sometimes you
take an L in life and that's why I mean
you read that book and you start
understanding that because it's not just
a technical side but it's a reason why
you take a loss somewhere on Louis
Vuitton in this one mall loses about
four hundred or two hundred dollars of
every month like ten years they'd lost
$3,000 and people are like that's the
stupidest thing in the world why are the
doors still open because it's the
[ __ ] best billboard in the [ __ ]
entire world and they're marketing right
there is crazy so they're losing their
okay great all the other stores are
doing well and I was like well some
people won't see eye to eye on that and
if you have it boom it's like you have
to really just understand this book kind
of talk it's just talking about business
even though it is the music business you
can apply to film it can apply to a lot
of things you know it's just a lot of my
people I deal with on a regular basis
are part of the music business yeah for
sure
and it's also when you read a book right
it's not just what's in the book what
time of your life do you read it to it
that's always a helpful
what about aliens believe you're not a
believer in short no in semi long look
man smoke a lot of weed map a lot of
mushrooms I've done a lot of acid they
say what you do LSD like 5:00 traffic
I'm gonna ask a lot you know in San
Francisco you know it's like you know
the Grateful Dead and all that [ __ ] with
a bad said again look man when someone
tries to tell you that the earth is like
a like a molecule grain of sand in the
galaxy and this galaxies like one got
like the [ __ ] uh the solar system
like that that's like one atom like [ __ ]
like how do you not sit there and get
high and think okay well how else the
English language created right what was
the first Ritz Oh
this means fire okay how do you know
what this means and how you know what
fire means and how do you know what you
know and you could go crazy thinking
about it okay be like fire stick I then
what's then what's I you know like how
do you the lid will just create it won't
point right and it makes sense to all of
us two plus two equals four
mathematically you can understand how it
makes that how is there not another
galaxy because we're one grain right has
to be this all there's no living nor
[ __ ] those so yeah there could be
somewhere seventy trillion zillion miles
away and they might have a different
language that's their language that
however make sense whatever and that you
know or based on whatever they have
different
what it is it could be a whole different
thing so I think it's possible but do I
think like et's here I don't [ __ ]
know man I wish it was you know what I
mean i believe the Bigfoot or the Loch
Ness monster and [ __ ] like that but I
don't know why'd you ask that question
ask every single person and and I would
say that like 95% or more say yeah
there's something else I don't know what
it is or is it little green man or is it
just some bacteria you know there's got
me something but uh the only thing I
take away from all of it is just let's
hope that we find them they don't find
us because whoever said the one waited
yeah I mean come on it is similar
mindset right I'm just like the world's
so [ __ ] big house they're not aliens
are some sort of life out there the
thing I always go to is like it's not a
question of is there life it's are they
actually more intelligent or more
developed than us right right and my
guess is probably not but I also think
that that's somewhat uh me just wanted
to go to sleep tonight thinking that
there's nobody out there there's gonna
come a day the earth you know kill us
all so what question you what'd you get
asked me one question to finish this
[ __ ] up what a one question you got for
me let me tell you some funny I've never
heard your show before until the Mark
Cuban one I don't know where that came
from and I just came with my own every
question I asked somebody all my
interviews the last question I asked him
is a asking anything you want I've never
heard that before my entire life really
last question is there anything you want
to ask me I always say that I have two
things to ask you if you don't mind
but that's please you said that first
thing is when you make your first
million and was off and what was the
first thing you bought after that yeah
so when I saw my first company or I'm
sorry second company was the the first
time that I was like damn like this is
real right and and you kind of get in
this position where you're just sitting
there and you're like nothing changed
but everything changed right it is kind
of at the same time and actually didn't
buy anything I literally bought nothing
here's why
here was my logic was uh it was one of
these things where I I was in the
military for six and a half years right
and when I came back I heard he gotten a
lot of the like I want to go buy [ __ ]
out of my system so I went to Iraq for a
year made much money ill for a kid at
twenty years old at the time all
tax-free and yeah it's not a lot of
money for real but when you're 20 years
old coming back and you've been in
college whole stuff and hop on a
motorcycle you know God you know all
this kind of crazy [ __ ] and there's
things where I remember you know I'd be
flying down the highway on a you know
ninja doing almost crazy stuff and then
I feel like a year or two of that you
kind of get it a little out of your
system and you start to realize like hey
man if I keep doing this like there's a
chance I might die right like I am I got
a very minor motorcycle accident like
literally in a parking lot type thing
right which is just enough to cope with
my chin whatever and you're like oh [ __ ]
like I'm lucky that I was going 15 miles
an hour or not you know 75 miles an hour
and so I think I just got got a lot of
that on my system and then you overlay
it with all the military stuff like
that's like the adrenaline rush of
adrenaline rushes right is uh is kind of
all the combat stuff so I think that
it's just one of these things where I
was kind of over it at that point and I
just kind of had a different bent but at
the same time I look back and I hear
stories of guys you know I I asked
pretty much every guy who comes on as a
Billy and I say what you do when you
first really had a billion dollars I
make a wild story it's right it's kind
of like the excitement of that I said if
I go in there I'm gonna have my head
removed I'm gonna make it look like
Optimus Prime or I might do like I don't
know something crazy so be all metal
though and then on top of that I'm never
gonna walk ever again she'll have people
carry me everywhere I go
um effect so he's taking questions uh
but the funny thing is let me go back to
your crate I was an avid motorcycle
riders 2008 even living in the hood we
had dirt bikes in the hood I was in the
bonus motorcycle gang
I rode bikes heavily i Hayabusa I did
195 on it I don't think I left my house
and did under once
see on a motorcycle in traffic even and
when I had my first chin there was my
wife Alma who leaked it
I've been on the news three times being
chased by helicopters high-speed chase
and I got away every time and I had to
get rid of the bikes all crazy bikes
anyways my last question is do you think
there's any correlation between 5gm
coronavirus no I'm probably not there on
that one uh uh uh here's my take is uh
so I was real early in taking it more
seriously no I won't say that I was like
full-on super serious but there's a
picture in January last year did 120
flights so you and I are very similar in
that we took a bunch of flights last
year my goal for 2020 was to not travel
that much so I had to take one flight in
January to go to this board meeting in
San Francisco and I went in New York to
go find the like n95 like that the real
good mast and they were all sold out I
was like that's weird so I ended up the
only thing I could get was like these
construction like dust masks yeah so I
said look it's better than nothing and I
was super freaked out I'm really not a
germaphobe but just for whatever reason
I was like this is kind of freaking me
out to get on this plane and sit there
breathe the same air with everybody all
stuff so I get on the plane put the mask
on take a picture you know screwing
around post on the internet everyone's
like oh you're an idiot whatever and now
I'm looking back a man I got to proof
back in January this [ __ ] was you know
no but but here's the thing is to me it
was less about like I thought it was
this serious it was just more of like
why not be overly cautious
but the the big moment for me was when
Zero Hedge zero heads just like a big
Twitter account how like 800,000
followers or something they were one of
the first people to really surface the
idea of the coronavirus wuhan the
virology lab they're in Wuhan and like
start trying to like really like
highlight some of these data points and
I remember saying look the odds that the
like conspiracy theory is true is very
low right at the time probably 5% or
less but I said there's more information
here than we've currently been told that
seems like a pretty big important fact
that I haven't heard
yet right that there's a biology lab
that studies coronaviruses in the city
where the outbreak happened whatever and
so it just set me off on this path of
like man I gotta learn about this myself
because I'm questioning the information
that I'm receiving from the traditional
sources and so I think 5g coronavirus
falls into that the lab falls into that
it's hard to tell what's true and what's
not true right but it just I walk away
just knowing that like we're probably
not getting all the information and
that's upsetting hear me out
I don't know the CEO of t-mobile is I
don't know the CEO of Verizon is or the
CEO of AT&T currently the actual only
company that carries real 5g is t-mobile
in the country just because your iphone
says LTE 5g does not mean you're getting
5g on that phone I found that out um why
would the CEO of Verizon in America want
to kill his family because there's no
way to get you can't you know you're
gonna get radiation period putting them
up people see the tires won't they're
not going up like that that's one thing
number two you can't give somebody you
can't handshake somebody and all of a
sudden 5g boom guess what now they got
5g that's not how it gets you know
transmitted you know I'm saying that's
one thing but coral virus isn't
currently 214 and more countries in the
world
5 G's not even in 100 countries so
that's that's what I want to set how to
explain it like it can't travel again
you can't cop on somebody and now of a
sudden they got the 5g and their immune
systems weak are now in things but June
and I'm saying it's just it sounds so
[ __ ] crazy like I couldn't imagine
being CEO of or the founder CEO of
Verizon being I feel you know what we're
gonna put these firefighters towers up
and then my son and my grandkids they're
all going to get sick because it just
sounds [ __ ] crazy I was just curious
what you thought and I just know yeah
I'm definitely I think that part of this
is people are sitting at home and
they're bored I think I should also do
right so it's like crazy things can we
come up with look after everyone got
their stimulus checks no one talked
about adding I've heard very less I've
heard less and let's talk about it but
right before that it was just going ham
I don't know if you saw this video I
haven't sent it to you somebody went and
they basically went through like black
Twitter right and they found all these
people who are tweeting who had
like very anti Donald Trump in the
current administration all stuff and
then when those checks hit there was
people tweeting like ah damn you got my
vote bro like you know you you real one
for this and like all stuff cuz they
because they were saying that they got
their trunk box and I was sitting there
and they made a whole like montage of
this thing and I was just laughing
because I was saying listen this this is
the game of the internet now right as
you go and you pick up a bunch of pieces
of information and you can twist it
however you want to tell whatever story
and not just and I was just like that's
probably going to be one of the biggest
things that we have to pay attention to
over the next few years is just what
information are you getting and how
accurate is that information right cuz
you can literally make the internet say
anything absolutely alright where where
can we send people where you want them
to go after I listen to this um you know
obviously any social platform at Ben
baller just like it says media and be a
ller but what I love people to do
because we're all seeing the same thing
and I don't look at my competition
anything we are obviously two different
people but I'm missing a business
category but if you go to Apple or
Spotify or go to stitch or go to
anything anywhere you listen to podcasts
you know listen to behind the baller
because behind the baller means it's no
jewelry no flash it's more my journey
getting there my journey where I'm going
me being a husband you'd be a better
father being a Renaissance man how I
help people get free game I like to talk
about people there's there's people who
are celebrities on my show of course
most of them are but like I have people
on my show who were bottom waitresses
and they're not on a 45 min logistic
company somehow someway you create these
stories that's like I want everyone to
understand and if you apply yourself and
you are smart you know it's possible now
is it gonna happen I don't know but you
have to at least look at things that
have glass full you know I just just I
would love you to send people to behind
the ball a podcast and other than that
man look a big supporter thinking now
because no one kind of really cool
conversation absolute behind the bollard
border talk [ __ ] I love it alright man
well I'll definitely link to it in the
show
description and we'll send people that
way I appreciate doing it alright thanks
man